Whenever I travel, I
like to meet the people.
So I'm in the heart of Mexico City,
I'm gonna walk around and say hola.
(speaking Spanish)
President Trump
wants to build a wall and he would like
Mexico to pay for it.
Would you like to make a donation?
Pure love.
Love?
You'd put love in there?
No. I need cash.
We were told that you guys were
going to pay for the wall and-
Oh really (chuckles) oh my God.
Would you like to donate to the wall?
And I'm going to sweeten the deal.
All right.
If you donate 500 pesos, you get
your name on a brick in the wall.
But you have to act now because there's
only going to be 800 million of these.
Oh really?
Yeah; for a thousand pesos, look at this.
You get an, I paid for the wall.
You like that, I paid for the wall?
(laughter)
And, I'm going to throw in this
Three Tenors CD because I like you.
Okay, so you got the brick,
You can get the bag, you
get the Three Tenors CD,
and throwing in, look at this right here.
(audience groaning)
That's how he spells it.
What's your name?
Cesar.
Is there anything you'd like
to say to President Trump?
(speaking Spanish)
If you speak in Spanish,
Trump won't understand.
If you speak in English,
he may not understand.
I want to hug the grandmother, please.
(cheering and talking)
(laughter)
He promised, he said Mexico would pay.
You know that I'm a
very famous movie actor.
Yeah, very handsome.
You from Malcolm in the Middle?
(laughter)
From Malcolm in the Middle?
Which one am I?
(laughter and clapping)
(growls, purrs)
Okay. Mexico!
Wow, that didn't go well.
They really stoned me on the growl.
(laughter)
The unhappiest selfie
anyone has ever taken.
(upbeat, lively music)
I was wondering, does he want to
donate money to build the wall.
(speaking Spanish)
No.
(laughter)
I'm here to get money money for the wall.
You know, Trump said you
guys would pay for it.
(laughter and clapping)
He didn't talk to any of you guys?
He said you guys were
playing for the wall.
We've been had!
That guy's a dishonest businessman!
(laughter)
Conan O'Ryan, close enough, pretty good.
That's a pretty good guess, Conan O'Ryan.
Nice to, nice to meet you.
Do you mind me holding on you like this?
I'm not letting you go, right?
All right, I'm not letting you go.
Let's see how long I can hold on to you.
(laughter)
I'm just gonna hold on to you.
Okay; did you have plans,
have to go somewhere?
Yeah, well you're not going there
because I'm holding on to you.
(laughter)
I'm not letting go, I'm not stopping.
What is your name?
Trump said that you would pay.
Trump... he said you would pay.
I'm not paying that.
Trump said you would pay.
I not pay nothing.
I put this...
(laughter)